تقدمت اداره احد احياء منطقه اسكس في
بريطانيا بطلب للمحكمه العليا من اجل وقف
خطط الحكومه لاستخدام قاعده عسكريه قديمه
في الحي لاواء طالبي اللجوء جاء هذا بعدما
اعلن وزير الهجره ان الحكومه تخطط لنقل
الاف من طالبي لجوء من الفنادق التي
انزلتهم بها الى قواعد عسكريه غير مستخدمه
وانها تدرس خططا لاسكانهم في سفن وتواجه
الحكومه ضغوطا متصاعده بسبب اخفاقها في
التعامل مع ازمه طالب الوجود
وتخطط الحكومه لواء طالبيه اللجوء في اربع
قواعد عسكريه سابقه كل قاعده تكفي لاواء
بين
15000 شخص يبلغ عدد طلبات اللجوء المتاخره
حاليا نحو 166 الفا بينما بلغ عدد طلبات
اللجوء لعام الماضي نحو 90 الف
الفا كما تدرس الحكومه ايواء طالبيه لجوء
في سفن او عبارات وتعرضت حكومه ريشيسوناك
لانتقادات من جهات عده بسبب خططها تلك
وتعتبر منظمات خيريه وانسانيه ان اماكن
الاقامه هذه غير ملائمه
بتاتا ومعزولا داعيا وداعيه الى معامله
طالبي اللجوء بكرامه تتدرع الحكومه بسعيها
لخفض التكاليف السنويه لايواء طالبيه
اللجوء في فنادق التي تبلغ مليارين
وثمانمائه مليون دولار
من امام احد الفنادق المستخدمه لواء
اللاجئين في منطقه
ويضعنا في تفاعل هذه القضيه
هل يتوقع ان تخضع الحكومه لهذه الضغوطات
لوقف هذه الخطوه
نعم مريم كما قلت نحن الان نقف امام نقف
امام احد الفنادق التي استخدمتها الحكومه
في ايواء هؤلاء اللاجئين اخر تفاعلات هذه
القضيه هو طعن القضائي او الطلبه القضائي
الذي تقدم به احد احياء مقاطعه اسكس من
اجل منع الحكومه من استخدام قاعده ويذرز
العسكريه
واللاجئين في تلك القاعده التابعه للحي
هناك انباء عن ان احياء اخرى تقع بها
قواعد اخرى تريد الحكومه استخدامها لهذا
الغرض تنويه فعل الشيء ذاته وبالتالي
نتوقع اجراءات قضائيه اخرى ضد الحكومه
الحكومه حتى الان
ذكرت بالاسم ثلاثه قواعد عسكريه في منطقه
اسكس
عفوا وسكس ومنطقه لينكنشر وايضا قاعده في
منطقه ريتشموند يعني الدائره الانتخابيه
لرئيس
المشكله حتى الان ان حتى لو استخدمت
الحكومه هذه القواعد الاربعه مريم فان ذلك
يعني
على الاكثر او على اكثر تقدير ثمانيه الاف
شخص طاقه استيعابيه لهذه القواعد الاربعه
في الوقت الذي تتحدث فيه الحكومه عن وجود
166 الف طلب متاخر من قبل طالبي اللجوء
وبالتالي هذا يظهر الى اي مدى هذه الخطوه
من قبل الحكومه لن تؤثر كثيرا في حل
الازمه حتى الان الحكومه تسعى من جانب اخر
لتمرير قانون ترحيل طالبي اللجوء خلال 28
يوما الى رواندا الى او الى دوله اخرى حتى
الان لم يتم ابرام اتفاقات مع دول اخرى
ولكن تنوي الحكومه ذلك حتى هذه الخطوه لم
تمر حتى الان من البرلمان وبالنسبه لكثير
من المراقبين والمحللين وايضا المعارضه
هنا
تصريحا من احد المسؤولين الرونديين قال ان
بلاده جاهزه لاستقبال حوالي 1200 لاجئ هذا
ايضا يشير الى ضاله الرقم مقارنه بحجم
مقارنه بحجم المشكله ما تسعى الحكومه
لتحقيقه في اللحظه الحاليه هو محاوله خفض
النفقات كما قلت الرقم يتعدى ملياري جنيه
وذلك عن طريق نقل طالبي اللجوء الى اماكن
اقل كلفه ومنها كما قلنا القواعد العسكريه
وحاليا هناك دراسه لنقلهم الى سفن في عرض
البحر اسد الله الصاوي من اماني احد
الفنادق المستخدمه لايواء اللاجئين في
منطقه شكرا جزيلا لك